mais voyons d'abord le reste de
l'actualité avec cette décision de la
cour de cassation qui ordonne un
supplément d'instruction dans la sphère
dils elle n'a donc pas casser purement
et simplement le précédent verdict des
assises qui avait reconnu patrick dils
coupables d'avoir tué deux enfants sur
une voie de chemin de fer à
montigny-lès-metz mais les éléments
nouveaux apportés par la défense
notamment la présence confirmée de
francis heaulme sur les lieux du crime
l'ont convaincu de relancer l'enquêté
valérie ermite et jacques chirat il y
croit depuis si longtemps pour la
famille de patrick dils
l'instant est solennel capitale pour
celle des enfants assassinés
le moment est douloureux le face-à-face
n'aura pas lieu
mais les regards sont parfois plus fort
que le move après un mois et demi de
réflexion
la cour de révision ordonne un
supplément d'enquêté une décision
rarissime
patrick dils n'est certes toujours pas
libre mais pour ses parents l'espoir est
désormais permis
vous voulez fêter ses 30 ans à la maison
heureusement
or par mende il commencera pas plus
communs sont en travaux
jusqu'à la fin sortir un jour et sortira
blanchi les une question de temps
maintenant c'est une question de
quelques semaines quelques mois
aujourd'hui j'irai si reculer pour mieux
sauter je pense que l'idée de la cour de
révision c2 devait tenir seulement sont
aussi pour permettre la cassation de
l'arrêt ajuste sa cour d'assises de la
moselle et un nouveau jugement par une
cour d'assises sereinement et à la
lumière de tous les nouveaux éléments
qui existent en postiers outre des
témoignages à décharge
le nouvel élément capital s'appelle
francis heaulme multirécidiviste du
crime
oh le méchant tueur en série notoire il
est aujourd'hui avéré qu'il a croisé le
chemin des deux enfants assassinés
la cour de révision demande donc qu'une
enquête approfondie soit menée pour les
familles des deux petites victimes
cette décision ne modifie en rien leurs
convictions voilà c'est bien c'est bien
tu vérifies gervais de patrick ville
avant qu'il ne se rétracte sont à leurs
yeux trop accablant s'excuse t il chaud
leur apprend dès maintenant une nouvelle
enquête qui commence une instruction au
terme de laquelle la cour de révision
décidera ou non d'annuler le procès de
patrick dils afin qu'il soit rejugé